time now for our uplift at eight where
we share stories that will bring some
joy to your day this morning we've got a
story about an awesome graduation gift
so let me tell you what happened jacoria
little and her brother Jalen have always
been close he's in the Army stationed at
Fort Bragg so she didn't expect to see
him at her high school graduation little
did she know he had planned a very big
surprise watch
[Music]
oh
[Applause]
Jalen who is in the Army's 82nd Airborne
Division drove nine hours to surprise
his little sister on her big day she
told us it meant the world to her
in that moment I was just very excited
and shocked to see him because I did not
think he was gonna be able to make it
and then that's when I started crying
and it was just very good moment because
I didn't think he was going to be there
my brother's not my best friend
oh jakoria plans to major in early
childhood education when she goes to
college in the fall I know we see these
videos often but they get me every
single time yeah every single time I
always love the moment where the person
doesn't realize it's the family member
and there's like this person's getting
very cold
lovely that was really I love it I
appreciate Vlad that was an uplift thank
you very much